[Music]
[Applause]
then we're doing the Bijan Robinson game
okay where which team okay which team
will draft Bichon Rob okay let's go
around the room before we bring him in
Seton will start with you where do you
think Bichon Robinson will go I think
it's going to be the Buffalo Bills
Buffalo Bills
what pick do they have it's a little
further down so maybe hopefully they
trade them okay Marvin
say the Eagles the Eagles wow that'd be
the 10th pick Todd
I was thinking Eagles too I think the
better story but I don't think it's
gonna fall that far would be the Cowboys
I wanted to pick Detroit at 18. there is
no way he gets past the LA chargers at
21. they could use him well depending on
Austin Eckler yes yes soon I see the
Falcons a lot too okay a lot of mocks
who's got Falcons I'm gonna go Cowboys
I'm gonna I'm gonna go Cowboys let's
bring in the Texas running back and uh
unanimous All-American all right where
do you think you're going to go Bichon
uh
uh you know I I don't know you know I'm
I'm really interested to see where I'm
gonna go next week
um I don't I don't have a say or a pig
but I'm just I'm just happy to be be
wherever wherever who picks me up okay
so no names now but have you been
promised by a team that if you're there
when they pick that they're taking you
uh
I don't know no no you they have to have
told you
did a team tell you you won't get past
us
uh team hasn't said that okay okay we
know we just been talking
how many how many interviews have you
done how many teams you met with
I've been to two teams two teams
um and like for for official visits to
their City only two teams and those
teams are
the Eagles and the Buccaneers of the two
teams I met with but I've been talking
to like
a lot of teams
um on zoom and stuff and and on calls so
but yeah those are the two places that
I've been if somebody hasn't seen you
play how would you describe
your style
yeah so for me you know I'm a guy that
that can do do everything on the field
um you can you know really versatile
line me up that receiver slot running
back you know do do everything have the
same value
um and then a guy that can you know
really make people Miss anywhere on the
field uh create a mismatch with guys on
the field and you know still be just as
effective and and even as blocking
um just little things little nuances and
I think that my vision on the field is
the thing that you know that that I've
been that I put in my game in and you
know
probably probably a lot of in my game so
I guess that would that would describe
me uh mainly
and it's good to throw in pass blocking
because you know that that's always good
to hear if you know if a quarterback's
like oh yeah and he can pass block so
that that that's good to have who is
your player comp who are you
people say you remind me of
uh I'll say uh LaDainian Tomlinson oh
okay that's pretty good yeah just style
styles in our game
um even just what he can do and and
catch the ball at the backfield and
still being effective after the catch
and then obviously his running style you
know how he you know can get from you
know zero to 60 really fast while still
you know in in weird situations of
trying to break tackles and trying to
you know career angles for himself so
and that's what I pride into my game as
well so I think that that's that's the
comp that that people tend to give me a
lot of
but I wonder about this that you know
talking to a scout who said your top
five Talent
but you won't but you won't go in the
top five
right yeah I mean you know I I
understand
um you know you know what people are
thinking and what people say
um
you know I believe that anything that
gets me is is such a blessing and I know
that guy's gonna put me in the in the
right position no matter where I'm at
um
but you know I can't I can't think well
I can't change what people are thinking
uh you know a team a team has where I'm
going to be at and a team knows where
I'm going to be at and if that's in the
top 10 if that's not then it's going to
be a blessing the other way so I'm just
trying to enjoy the moment and you know
people are going to have opinions but
you know we we all don't know so we're
just all gonna see you know in a week
are you a Cowboys fan
I'm not a team fan you know I've never
been a team fan I've always been like a
player fan
um that that's the that's the kind of
guy I've been so I've been a player fan
like growing up
um you know my grandpa he was a past 12
official so he was really he can never
be a fan of any team so he would like
bring it in the household of like y'all
like you don't gotta be a fan of nobody
just pick a player y'all like and your
dad Grandpa Cleo so he was there in the
in the Pac-12 you loved Reggie Bush
yeah how did you not end up at USC
uh I mean you know just just a lot of
prayer took me to Texas but I think that
the you know USC was definitely a in the
cars for me um that was in my top four
and you know they actually asked Reggie
if if I can wear number five
um if I went there and he he approved he
said yeah
um so it it came down really close
really close just because like that
would have been like a cool story and a
cool thing but
I knew I had to go to Texas man and I
mean it worked out but USC was
definitely definitely in the cars back
back then but also the nil money
I mean you're like the first generation
of name image and likeness football
players so how does it work
when you go to Texas when it when do you
hear how do you hear from a company that
they want to sponsor you or you're going
to endorse their product
yeah so I mean even just me going to
Texas
um there's so many resources and so many
like brands that are affiliated with
with the university and you know for me
you know it was when it happened
um it all started you know in the summer
and you know my marketing Guy Brian
Bernie you know he was the guy that that
came out and was like we need to attack
this as fast as possible and that's what
we did
um
so there was a lot of like big Brands
like canes and uh like Verizon that
started coming uh really fast so we just
started we was trying to utilize
everything well when do you get the car
when do you get the sports car
okay so that was this that was last
summer that was last summer so that the
you mean the Lamborghini yeah
that was uh yeah last summer uh you know
we we came we came together
um me and uh the guys that did you know
how to drive a Lamborghini I did not I
did not but I I learned real fast
and then and then when somebody says we
want to have a mustard
yeah so even those guys I mean David and
Craig those the other you know majority
owners of the of the company you know we
we came together as well and was like we
need to make this mustard a thing uh the
Bichon mustard and period in six months
just became
because it became a huge deal so it's
pretty cool he's uh Bijan Robinson Texas
running back he's not sure where he's
going but I think he knows where he is
going to go or maybe he wants to go I I
I I get the sense you know where you
want to go but you can't say that
um also you started out as running back
you know and it didn't go well when you
first started out playing running back
did it
yeah so it was a I was five years old
um six years old and I started the flag
football league and I started that
running back and my first
couple drives I I was running backwards
so I'll get the ball and start running
backwards
um wait you ran in the wrong direction
yeah right the wrong direction I was
running to the other team's End Zone
and you wondered why nobody was chasing
you yeah I was like I'm good
best player you played against
best player I played against I'll
probably say Will Anderson
um you know just how How Sound he is as
a player you know he he never really
misses assignments so you got to be you
know really focused in and really honing
on your details playing against a guy
like that because he can start off on on
the line he can end up at linebacker
like you really just don't know where he
where he's at a play at so I think that
he was a guy that really gave us you
know a huge especially myself a huge
challenge to to get past him
um but I think that he's the the best
one that I've played you know my in my
college career I saw on Instagram your
Instagram you met LeBron back in
December yeah yeah that was uh how did
that come about
yeah so when I when I signed up with
with my agency you know clutch
um you know I was in I was in LA and we
you know kind of went to the to the
Lakers game
um
and I mean it was all kind of set up
that we met Lebron after the game
um and that was just like a huge moment
just because like I that's been my my
favorite player my guy for you know all
my life uh so hearing you know what he
had to say about about myself and the
respect that he had for my game and you
know how he watched me in my college
career it was it was a good moment to to
hear from I would say the greatest
player
um in my generation to play the game uh
just to hear like what he had to say
about me and it was it was a lot of
confidence a lot of motivation for what
I'm trying to do in the league as well
so it was it was pretty cool meeting the
guy like that um and talking to him for
sure what kind of football player you
think LeBron would make
I mean that dude would be a beast I
think he'll be a maybe like a tight end
receiver
um
and just absolutely dominate especially
at his size and his speed
it'll be hard to stop in well we look at
a big guy in football yeah and then
there's a big guy in the NBA and there's
a big difference in those sizes of
what's big in the NFL that could be like
you know six six five you know 280 where
LeBron is six nine 270. yeah that's
that's what I'm saying like and he and
he looks like a receiver like he could
play a receiver
um which is which is crazy to me but
that's why I think that he would he
would definitely dominate If he if he
played the game well he played he was a
high school uh he was all stayed as a
tight end or wide receiver yeah I think
receiver yeah yeah not bad uh do you got
the suit picked out
I do I do so so I'm actually gonna go
try it on today and make sure everything
is is correct but it's it's gonna be a
nice a nice surprise you know what I
would do when you're drafted yep instead
of hugging the commissioner yeah hand
him some of your mustard
that would actually be like pretty
awesome yeah
yeah you know okay see that's that's an
idea okay I'll go back
and uh maybe some chicken fingers don't
be surprised if it actually happens hey
I'm telling you
that's just Next Level I mean your
marketing department I'm sure does a
good job but I do a great job
wow I'm the Lamborghini of marketing
guys just to let you know I I believe it
too
I think it's great I think uh do that
and and just remember the suit that you
wear on draft night they're going to be
looking at that for decades and you
don't want them to look back and go man
what was Bijan wearing right be clean
just just be clean no mustard color
and maybe a tie if you want to give a
little acknowledgment to Texas a little
bird orange if you want okay but be
clean
and and that way it lives on forever we
don't look back and go man what was he
thinking
yes clean make sure you clean yes sir
now now I'm going to tune into the draft
now because I know what you're going to
do there's going to be product placement
you and the commissioner
ah and you're going to go to the Dallas
Cowboys and it's going to be a great
story going to be a great story
um hey good luck okay and uh congrats on
your success and uh we'll be watching on
draft day Matt I appreciate you for
having me having me on the show man
that's a bichon Robinson first of all
with a name like Bichon you got to be a
star and uh unanimous All-American and
uh great first John great